what is going on guys so we just saw a
film called the other side of the door
this is my friend Matthew Brando Matthew
runs a YouTube channel of his own he
loves movies you also review toys yes
and you want my best friends yes and we
were going to go see this film for fun
we we didn't really have any plans to
review the other side of the door and
then we saw it and we decided to review
it for you yeah and the honest truth is
I can't really think of a way to review
this movie without actually just delving
into everything upfront this movie is
horrible it's acid Balls's it's
everything that you could possibly think
of that's terrible I hated this movie I
will say it has some positive redeeming
qualities you actually hate at the
beginning I started with you know
getting into it I started like it and
then for me it's like this is good and
then and then you start laughing out
loud my idea okay he hates it to know
the basic plot this movie is a mother
and a father are living in Mumbai India
they've lost their son in a tragic
accident and when she learns from her
housekeeper that there is a temple
somewhere that's abandoned that maybe
she can go to this temple and
communicate with her son for just one
more time but she's like don't open the
door there's a door that separates the
human world from the dead world and
you're not supposed to open it you can
hear the Dead's voices but if you open
it you're basically screwed guess what
she does
opens the door and the Sun comes into
the real world and starts possessing
everyone killing people and look okay
we've seen movies like this before there
was part of it that was slightly
original I was like okay takes place in
India that's yeah I haven't seen this
culture in a supernatural horror film in
a while you know that takes at least
that came out in America right that was
kind of cool the best part of the movie
I actually thought was their housekeeper
from here on let's just get into full
spoilers if you wanted to see the other
side of the door I'm sorry there are so
many things that happen throughout this
entire runtime that make no sense it's
one of those things where it's a
supernatural movie so the writers and
the director just thought well hey we
can just put whatever and they'll just
believe it because ghosts like presents
there's a scene where they're sitting at
a restaurant and she's just there eating
food and all of a sudden like
cockroaches are just crawling out of the
walls and her food and everywhere and
there are people like going like this
with cockroaches in the restaurant and
then of course then it split second it
all disappears and she's just like yeah
typical cliche bullshit the funniest
part of this movie for me okay it's not
technically funny cuz this tragic
accident but I laugh my ass off okay
they're walking through the street the
mother and her daughter and they
approach a car and there's an accident
there's this man crushed underneath the
car and he's laying there and there's
EMS workers and cops and people looking
at him and he's all like dead and all of
a sudden it goes ah there's no
explanation no it's crazy because this
film had so much potential but does
stupid shit like that yeah or it has a
jump scare and then you laugh at it
you're not supposed to laugh at and the
jump scare actually has some potential
like scary essentials down your spine
but you just laugh at it does the wrong
thing the scene where the mother is
walking into the room and she's like hey
Lucy to her daughter and she just turns
around goes oh how many times are
jump-scares just like this you know
hollowface with black eyes just like
come on I've seen this a billion times
already like a broken open yes there was
one audience member in our theatre who
also had some things to say there's the
owner guy sitting in the front and this
is the second best part of the movie for
me the little girl is in her room
talking to somebody and the mothers
approaching the door and opens the door
and the little girl just stops it goes
oh hi mommy
and she's like well who are you talking
to my dolls the older guy was just like
yeah is full out loud yeah yeah when the
boy starts haunting their house all of
their plants die all of the fish died
and what character doesn't seem to
notice this hmm dad is a dad because
he's just like the dad he'll call be
like hey I have to stay at work for like
two more hours oh good because the
writers didn't know what else to do with
him yeah exactly
he's kind of just thrown away he never
noticed that every plant and every tree
surrounding their house literally dies
turns brown
and the two birds and their birds for
somehow the dog survived the dog
survives for a while towards the end of
the movie the little girl has the knife
and she's now become possessed by this
boy and she's wandering around the
little girl is now possessed and this is
acting it's not the greatest guys it's
really not and it was it was
cringe-worthy and sad the dad comes into
the kitchen and she has the knife and
everything and the dads not believing
that this little girl's possessed the
dad is like no no my wife's crazy and
the little girl just goes with the knife
and if you like this really awkward
close-up of the dad is like oh it was a
great talk about the little shaman
people like they actually started the
downfall for me for this movie I'm like
what the hell is this I was like please
don't play out the rest of the movie and
it does all about this I think the most
hilarious part is we have the mom and we
had the little girl and she's pointing
the fish or the fish she's putting the
birds in the water to go away because
they died and mommy oh my dick I have
there the shaman guy on the watch out
for that guy
our scam honey no thank you Anna
like what that's jumpscares for you this
movie is filled with the cliches every
time someone goes like this oh there's
always like some screaming dead face
like the ring poor cliches 101 do we
have birds flying out of holes
accompanied by jump scares yes we do do
we have a creepy old like deformed lady
crawling on the ground with hair
covering her face and she's like oh
really
yes we of course have that because every
horror movie now has to have that do we
have the turning around and seeing like
a deformed mouth open face yes we have
it it's everything family pet dies
family pet dies the animal can of course
see everything of course a child can see
everything and the adults are just like
oh this is kind of funny and interesting
oblivious yeah it this movie is nothing
but cliches it started out with a
possibly interesting idea and just
divulged into the laziest writing
cliches you could think of it the
biggest one for me was the dad character
he's just there and the writers
literally can't think of anything to do
with them so they just every scene he's
like hey I'm gonna be a couple more
hours at work see you later oh good now
we have some alone time in this creepy
house and
is actually pretty crazier so it's a
little bit original but it just lost me
where she's in the dead son's little
bedroom and then Oh good night Oliver I
guess you know Oliver's starting to come
back to life or whatever boom a book
falls from the bookshelf cause the
jungle book his favorite book and it was
the chair comes up Omar reaching honey
that's ready go I was like this this is
crazy what am i watching right yeah why
did we decide to go to this movie yeah
we drove what we drove like a half an
hour ago see this movie because it's
only opening on like 500 theaters and we
were just kind of like have fun see it
and it was so bad we had to review it
essentially I hate this movie I really
do the acting is terrible the best
performance of the movie is their
housekeeper
this story's cliche the direction is
it's just there it's very like hey let's
just handheld this you know it's almost
like it felt like every other scene was
like let's just do it handheld yes I
could only care yeah the ending is the
worst I guess the mother decides to like
trade places with the dead kid
and like talks to like the creepy lady
who goes like oh I don't get to see your
face guess what she does of course you
that's the horror face yeah and I guess
she switches places with the dead son
somehow yes she sacrifices herself yeah
I don't know exactly actually what
happened because then we cut to her in
like the dead world and you hear the dad
has now gone to the temple and is trying
to communicate with her and she's like
no no and then you see the dork kind of
go like that and then it ends and you're
like wait so what is she afraid about is
she afraid of that now she has the
opportunity to haunt the real world now
and but that's her family were trading
very members but she like knew like she
understood what was happening and she
was like no so was she worried about
yeah this film breaks its own rules a
lot of the times like when the
housekeeper says you can burn your
belongings of the child and then
everything will go away and then they
burn the belongings and the movie
continues like yeah what the hell you
just said that this was gonna work but
it doesn't yeah well what was the point
of that it's all bad it's really bad
it's filled with nothing but cliches it
has some really laugh-out-loud moments
but the movie isn't worth seeing I like
you couldn't pay I'd rather watch gods
of Egypt a thousand more time
times then see this movie again like I
said it's one of those movies that
doesn't explain any of its crazy
supernatural stuff you're just supposed
to be like oh it's just a ghost movie so
everything just is fine yeah why'd the
guy who got run over go like this and
look at the lady yeah in broad daylight
in front of a hundred thousand people
right why'd that happen the difference
between like Gaza Egypt and this movie
is this movie so torturous to watch
compared to god's egypt you can actually
laugh at it exactly that's exactly right
hopefully you have like an older man the
theater who goes no right
yeah whatever anything happens so I'm
personally going to give the other side
of the door which by the way should just
been called beyond the door or something
that wasn't such a long ass title and F
I'm gonna 1 out of 10 one out of 10 yeah
I mean basically that's an F so don't
see the movie like I said not worth your
time or your money it's a terrible film
but it did have some laughs thank you
Matt for joining me on this video thank
you for having me I appreciate it
definitely check out matched channel
Matt does a lot of toy reviews he does a
lot of in-depth discussion on film
he loves dress parks Star Wars I with
Jurassic Park shit him blown up door oh
nice definitely check out matched
channel he has a video that he just made
that is a really good in-depth analysis
of the possibilities that rocky v had to
be a good movie and I think it's your
best video I'll link that in the
description below definitely check that
out and give them a subscription I think
is worth your time thank you
thank you so much as always guys for
watching and get stuck
you